um are there any common errors that you
can mention relationship to culture and
Country all the errors that are
mentioned earlier where General Muslims
throughout the world there are some
errors which are made mainly by people
living in certain country belong to
certain culture for example in the
Indian subcontinent that are people
living in India in Pakistan and Sri
Lanka during Ramadan many of the Muslims
in the night they play night
cricket and they spend
most of the time in night Cricket rather
than doing I of Allah subhana tala so
this playing night Cricket is more
common in the Indian
subcontinent now if you go to the Arab
countries especially the gulf countries
there many of the
officers many of the working places that
is in the market Etc they change their
timings they hardly work for a couple of
hours in the daytime and they open most
of the time during night so what happen
it encourages people to do shopping in
the night rather than the day and they
get more
business and they're inviting people
rather in spending time in Remembering
Allah subhana wa ta'ala Muslims spend
their time in shopping and eating during
night time and furthermore those people
who are employed in the shops they
forced to come at night time because
it's the duty so these Muslims are even
preventing their
employees rather than remembering Allah
subhana taala they're involving
themselves in business and spending most
of their time in activities which are
not according to the Sunnah